so firing toward the International Space
Station at 17,000 miles per hour
probably didn't seem like such a big
deal to Kate Rubin's that's cuz she is
no stranger to inhospitable places as a
biologist she's worked on the Congo
doing fieldwork on monkey pox and
handled some of the world's most
dangerous pathogens and a biosafety
level 4 facility that launch was back in
July
Ruben's recently returned earth after
four months of serious work on the space
station specifically of the genetic
variety
Ruben's and her astronaut cohort set out
to determine if they could sequence DNA
in microgravity because the only thing
cooler than sequencing DNA on earth is
doing it in space incredibly it worked
in fact the sequencing actually turned
out better in space after we got done
with the tech desk part of it we really
shot right out of the gate and ended up
sequencing a little bit over 2 billion
base pairs by the time I left
Ruben's also ran experiments for
culturing cells seeing how the microbes
are evolving in the microgravity of
space but working with such sensitive
experiments in microgravity is a whole
lot different than on earth
the big Delta is you're floating and
you're controlling controlling your
motion with your feet while you're doing
cell culture there Ruben's now coming
out of the quest airlock to join
Williams just as humans even got the
chance to work outside in the fresh air
on two spacewalks as in highly
choreographed spacewalks she spent
hundreds of hours practicing you're
working very very hard but there is
there's a few minutes here and there
where the grounds may be talking about
something or you have to put your tools
down and wait and just getting a chance
to look through your visor and and see
the planet go by was incredible but all
good space things must come to an end on
Saturday Ruben's boarded a Soyuz
spacecraft with astronauts from Russia
and Japan and plummeted back to earth
after the initial shock of the
parachutes deploying she says the trip
was relatively peaceful
here just a little bit along for the
ride and then there's another huge
impact when you land that's about like a
car crash and you just the capsule
bounces and rolls a little bit and
everything settles down at some point
and we looked out the window we saw dirt
and so we were pretty sure that we hit
planet Earth the point
and thank the stars for that welcome
home ribbons